and the reds with tony santeon on the
bump
santi has been pretty good he's done a
nice job of see the three starts here
and his last start was really good
1-1
chop to third big bounds suarez
retreating outfield grass thrown shortly
one no chance to get tatis he's way too
quick
runner on first and now the national
league player of the week stands in left
hand hitting jake cronin north
sharply hit and that is a fair ball
heading for third is tatis down to the
right field corner fernando's gonna be
waved around he will score and two third
base goes kodaworth and the padres take
a one-nothing lead in the first
back to the stretch it looks like on two
and two high target from stevenson and a
fastball hit in the air out to deep
right field castianos gives way to the
center fielder akiyama onto the warning
track he makes the catch plenty deep to
get cronenworth home another sacrifice
fly for manny machado and at two to
nothing padre lead in the first
up the middle nice backhand pick farmer
pops up from his left knee throw to
first in time
first start for craig's damn in 2021
remember the last start he made was in
the wild card series against st louis
where he was spectacular in that
finishing game
see 33 games he's worked in already
and he will get nick castianos who came
off a big game last night with seven
rbis
ground ball to short could be two the
second for one on to first it is two so
to the plate comes tyler stevenson and
stevenson lines it right back up the
middle into center field for a base hit
india will score the reds are on the
board and it's tyler stevenson the reds
rookie catcher driving in
his fellow rookie jonathan india
2-2
swing swinging a miss and he strikes him
out to end the inning
one two swing and a miss he struck him
out breaking ball down
[Applause]
gets it down santiana is going to go to
third base and safe there third first is
late everybody's safe base is filled
with friars and tommy pham the hitter
fly ball headed to right center field
right fielder castiano's getting himself
ready he'll make the catch osmer is
tagging at third base throw to the plate
he's going to be cut off and the padres
take a 3-1 lead a sac fly for tommy pham
3-1 pods here in the second now two on
and two out and tatis at the plate
lined to left field and a base hit
winker comes up with it as carratini
will stop at third base doesn't have the
greatest speed and
the padres have him loaded now with two
down bases filled with friars again and
we'll bring up jake cronenworth 2-2
swing into this he struck him out
machado high fly
deep and playable center akiyama
[Applause]
swing of the miss on the payoff a high
heater three k's for santiago
[Applause]
roped past the dive of jonathan india
tomas vera
athletic trainer david bell alongside
and winces a little bit there yeah bases
are loaded again for the padres
and jorge mateo will pinch it 0-2
swing into this breaking ball down to
the way
gets the strikeout to leave him loaded
second time at as many innings
[Applause]
swinging a minute soft balance and
ramirez strikes out first batter that he
faces
line to right and on the sinking liner
will myers able to make the catch
and a fly ball
headed to center field where trent
grisham comes in to make the catch build
of the cab high
tommy pham stands in one for one with a
single and a sacrifice
that's this one schulten out towards
deep right center field akiyama back at
the wall and that ball is gone home run
for tommy pham his ninth of the year and
the padres take a 4-1 lead makes this
mid-90s fastball stays inside a perfect
balance through that ball a different
sound runners on first and second one
out in the top of the fourth inning
andre is a four to one lead on the reds
and trent grisham coming up
her ball and it is lined into right
field for a base hit colonel north being
waved around from second he's going to
try and score the throw will be cut off
and the padres take a 5-1 lead
rbi single for trent grisham as
cronenworth comes in
two on two out and here's shogo
akiyama
into right center down base hit wave is
on a third meier's shallow right center
fires to the plate the slide the tag
bottoms out
and they're going to take another look
what do we see on replay all that's in
that toes on the plate save
jesse winker has just four hits in his
last 31 at bats you know what that means
lark he's due oh yes
winker
bomb deep right center to the power
stacks
eyeballs the dugout a two-run tater and
the reds are right back in it 5-4
grounded right side
india sliding stop pumps to his feet
side arm throw in time
excellent recovery
pops it up
suarez and foul
a huge one pitch out
ace is loaded again for the padres they
left him loaded in the second and the
third
one two
strike three called
fastball at the bottom of the zone
hosmer furiously disagrees
did he go
he did
and hearing it from the dugout is hunter
windelstein
takes his mask off and barks back and
has ejected somebody
i don't know who he got
cosmo
so it was hosmer who was tossed yeah
that's the third pitch of last inning
runner goes grounded to third backhand
pick suarez dropped it
i think he thought it was foul a race to
third on the cover do a little tag slams
into him knocked off the bag out of push
i believe he did think that ball was
foul
and david bell jogs out suarez is being
yanked by the back of his jersey by
farmer
cronin worth is no slouch one for three
tonight
reds are trying to stray the bases
loaded for the fourth time
oh one
hopped up
suarez and foul ground makes the catch
one down and here's castellanos and you
can hear the chants of mvp every time
line to right center field and diving is
myers to make the catch
now a throw to first trying to double
him off cannot but a great catch by
myers in right field
back to back two out walks cronin worth
a tough out comes to the plate two-two
crush to right castellanos
on the warning track makes the catch
and mark malanson into the game for the
padres trying to get the final three
outs and a win in the first game of this
road trip for the padres
on the ground to third there's machado
who's right at the lip of the grass
fires across for out number one of the
ninth inning
swinging a mess he struck him out two
down in the ninth inning for melanson
eight straight reds retired can jonathan
india
recreate the majesty of his moment a
week plus ago
1-0 to india
on the ground to second base kim to
first in the padres win
mark mullanson comes in as a one two
three ninth inning and the padres hold
on and win game one of the series